I'm so glad these things exist focus
studies weren't a thing when I was cool
they might even think we're in this one
do prison school day very very deep
the idea is like this in the last few
years where you've been letting math
nights you learn a topic like say
geometry right and then we say okay well
what real-world kinds of applications of
Chioma treat avec where do you find
triangles into your life we define
rectangles circles cylinders etc okay so
you take a topic you start from that and
then you try and look at different areas
but that topic applies to yeah so we've
seen this before
in the focus studies we're kind of
turning that around we're saying look
there's one particular area of what I'm
interested in and I want to tell me all
the mathematics that relate to this area
okay so it's kind of like a bowl
project-based sort of focused way of
learning now when you have a look we've
been looking at like a 1 and then what
etc would be treating them as quite
separate walks we're gonna be doing one
two three more or less continuously this
is basically our work to the end of the
turn okay focused study driving one
focus a drive to sixty ninety three if
you have a look at what these are
talking about in a nutshell what this is
is how do you get a car and all the
finance stuff how do you keep the car
and will the finance stuff and how do
you stay alive in the car that's it very
simple okay so if you want to understand
always three ideas get it keep it stay
alive there's lots of mathematics that
will help you with that you can say for
example one day here I'm just saying
like the two main ideas we'll be looking
at are stopping distance so you might
remember there was a question in your
rates question in the question in the
paper you just did which is about
someone looking at their phone while
they were driving and then looking up
right so that idea of going through time
and then there's like a reflex suppose
they see someone to the right of their
name break okay we call that stopping
distance how long does it take you to
stop your vehicle is there not BAC sense
what okay so blood-alcohol content is a
very very important
there's lots of mass that governs it so
we're gonna look at that under fricassee
driving 3 so this is just a broad
overview I will also show you what's the
best way to do this yeah this will just
finish we have once you give like nine
nine topics no more topics exercises
that we're going to look at and you can
see how they have broken up across the
different little modules that we look at
you don't need to write this down I will
draw your attention to as we go through
but today we're gonna have a look at
cost of purchase financier purchase
which is you know all the extra stuff
where you can't actually afford to buy
your car that's the next part so that's
all about getting the car yeah these are
costs that start to be worried about
once you've got the car and you've had
it for any amount of time and then all
this stuff down the bottom you can see
these are all the safety kind of focus
bits right and you can also sort of
notice it reaches that little branches
in that's that maybe we haven't looked
at this year that much we looked at some
stats and I see averages medians don't
stand deviation range those kinds of
things so we're going to address some of
those at the end of this you okay but
that gave you kind of a on bird's eye
view of what mathematics driving is
about its economic sense well you buy a
car today
in my life I bought four cars two used
to new ladies of the abnormal these are
not the actual positive world but these
are the models okay and I currently have
this one and this one but I Drive that
one so anyway um you can see I'm biased
towards Japanese cause I I have one for
cars bikes into you into you and it
seems to me every time I've done this
right like I I don't know if anyone
likes going to the dentist but I prefer
going through the dentist I'm applying a
car right behind your car is one of the
most crazy complicated like it seems
like the dealer is intentionally trying
to confuse you in what you have
paintball all the different forces
involved and by the way is a very very
good reason not a valid reason but a
good reason why they are actually doing
that - you're intentionally confusing
deep into what are the costs and really
it should be plural what are the costs
involved when you are purchasing oh yeah
there are six main ones that I want to
tell you about they're on your table
there are six main costs and they are
paid to three different groups of people